oh hi don't you think that video games
just put too much of an emphasis on guns
these days like isn't it all just too
much don't don't games need to embrace
and grow and mature and evolve and you
know give us more and exciting ways of
murdering our fellow human beings I feel
the same way
fortunately this week's games are all
about variety you can kill people with
tomahawks you can kill them with katanas
or you can kill them with a good
old-fashioned bow and arrow finished
with Assassin's Creed 3 think again if
you're craving more colonial American
action Ubisoft has it for you with the
release of the tyranny of King
Washington on February 19 in this
downloadable add-on pack you play a
what-if scenario that messes with
history imagining that George Washington
usurped the throne of America and
threatened our fragile democracy as the
lovable scamp ratone hawk a dog you got
to take down the evil king this is the
first of three episodes that will retail
for $9.99 each Ryden the protagonists of
Metal Gear Solid 2 now has his very own
game again Metal Gear Rising revengeance
has been in the works forever and now
courtesy of Platinum Games the
developers of Bayonetta it's finally
here go nuts on dudes and robots and
helicopters in everything with write-ins
katana using the right analog stick to
aim your sword slashes with razor-sharp
precision slice off an enemy's left hand
and you'll get bonus points to spend on
upgrades the cinematics are as totally
crazy as we've come to expect from the
Metal Gear series crisis that gorgeous
shooter that your PC can just barely run
is also back this week playing as the
Prophet one more time you wake up in a
new york city that's been covered with a
big old geodesic dome thing causing
trees and rain forests and such to
spring up in the middle of Manhattan
now you could shoot all these people
with guns if you wanted to but why
bother when you have the world's most
kick-ass bow and arrow mark your targets
before heading into a fight then sneak
in and silently take down everybody well
after all those novel ideas maybe we can
dream even bigger I mean a future in
which triple-a games aren't just about
killing people has got to be right
around the corner I almost got myself
with that one that was good